are you lying
kaylie cuoco has some explaining to do
unbelievable
over the weekend the big bang theory
star shared this sweet anniversary post
with her hubby
carl cook and it totally jokingly
offended her
ex and former co-star johnny galecki
it's
very sad it all started when the 35 year
old actress posted
this puckered up masked pic with carl
writing alongside it quote
happy five years to the weirdest person
i know i don't remember
a moment before you entered my life what
a boring life that must have been
oh we're having a bla carl's the best
we're doing really well
well johnny who dated kaylee for two
years during the 2000s early on during
the sitcoms run
took notice and hilariously hit up the
comments writing simply
um kaylee's response lol
i just love it later the flight
attendant star shared a screen grab of a
funny text exchange with johnny
where they had a laugh over an article
about his comment
with kaylee adding a gif that says
that's the t
the heart wants what the heart wants
leonard
okay of course johnny and kaylee played
on-screen loves
penny and leonard on the hit cbs comedy
and
last november during an appearance on
dax shepard's armchair expert podcast
i remember when we when we did the pilot
i was just
crushing
glecky right yeah kaylee spilled the tea
about dating her co-star for two years
in real life
early into the show's run which lasted
from 2006
to 2016. we got together and just
fell mad for each other for about two
years but then we broke up
kaylee went on to marry tennis player
ryan sweeting in 2013
but the pair officially divorced in 2016
and in 2018 she married professional
horseback rider carl
but through it all kaylie and johnny
have remained
great friends you have green eyes i've
just noticed i've never looked at your
eyes before 12
years you know my freaking eyes were
green
are you lying
unbelievable beautiful eyes they're
gonna cut this
i'm this close to you so many days like
not that much
let's see that's all unscripted
oh my god um i don't even remember the
question
johnny can not handle doing interviews
with me